[Music]
new york city just wrapped up fashion
week and one of the designers who
attended was john gagliano and uh if you
don't know here's a photo of mr galliano
and here's another photo of mr
yeah well anyway galliano is once again
once again involved in a controversy
with the jewish people uh here is
galliano on the front page of the new
york post just a couple days ago
because what happened the newspaper says
that galiano was wearing a hat that
hasidic jews typically wear and that
that's inappropriate especially in light
of his past controversy involving
anti-semitism now we wanted to
straighten this out we reached out to
galliano's people get his side of the
story but the only person that responded
was john galliano's brother joe galliano
he's a group just play along he's agreed
is it really that hard you know
the guy has a brother okay and he's
agreed to talk to us
right now no other show just us
so please welcome via satellite via
satellite from paris joe galliano let's
get him in there
thank you
yes
yes that's definitely paris can you hear
me joe
as clear as a bell cone okay now
joe how do you feel about the outfit
your brother was wearing in the new york
post photo does he owe jewish people an
apology
not at all
my brother and i love jewish people
okay but given his previous comments the
outfit he was wearing was very very
provocative don't you think
that's absurd
the jewels are god's chosen people and
he chose to dress like them
but joe shouldn't he just stay away from
that kind of thing just to avoid even
the possibility of offending people
oh come now
my brothers
my brother's as innocent as a baby in a
box full of puppies
all right well it's pretty clear that
you and your brother you know what
you're doing you're just trying to over
compensate that's what you're doing
you're overcompensating
what are you talking about
you're being absurd cozy ponzi
well it seems obvious that you and your
brother are doing things to suck up to
the jewish community to try and to get
favor with them
it doesn't sir
we don't suck up to anybody gentile
or jew
[Applause]
all right you're done you please go
we're done here you gotta just go you
just gotta leave i decide when we're
done and we're done i am out of here all
right goodbye
goodbye and good readiness
[Applause]
thank you